[Music]
a little bit of work man that don't
scare us i get up i go hard like i'm
george harris make plays break lanes
push way
[Music]
welcome to fight night flashbacks i have
a special guest in the house it is
michael chandler the great michael
chandler all the way from nashville
tennessee mike we are we're gonna go
over a few of your key fights you have
so many fights it was tough to pick
i want to start with this first one it
was your last bellator fight against
benson henderson yep because i feel like
this was such a pivotal moment in your
career because
this is the fight where
you know you lose this one kind of
dictates where you're going to go a
little rest of my life yeah the rest of
my life
this was this was the most uh yeah this
is the most pressure i've ever felt not
not just the fact that it was the last
fight on my bellator contract choosing
to go to free agency but anybody who
knows and has watched benson henderson
he's durable it's really hard to look
good against benson henderson in a lot
of ways because you never really get him
hurt he never he never looks bad he
always has that
stoic look on his face not gonna break
him there's nothing going on it's almost
like he's just hanging out doing nothing
in there
so i was just you know quite frankly
very nervous that i was even even if i
won i was confident i was gonna win but
i thought i might have had a lackluster
performance against a guy
who just you can never look good against
yeah it's tough to look good against
them you talk about a hall of famer man
yeah benson henderson's a freaking
savage a little story about benson
henderson will start the fight when i
was first uh when i decided to try mma
i just looked up my local this is in
denver um i looked at my local like jiu
jitsu gym yeah and so it's my first i
was in my car i'm like i don't want to
do this and i was selling supplements
door-to-door like pursuit of happiness
style
and uh i'm sitting in my car i'm like i
really want to do this and i was like
let's just try it out so i go and uh
there's a gentleman behind me i hold the
door open and i go what's up man he goes
what's up and i go oh it's my first day
goes oh cool yeah it's like my second
and i go oh what are you doing he goes
um plans to make to the ufc i go [ __ ] me
too man what's your name goes benson
henderson what yeah in in colorado
colorado before he moved to arizona yeah
his coach was john uh john cruz
john crouch yeah and his gym they
started in denver and they moved arizona
they moved to arizona and he uh
his uh
wrestling coach um leester bowling was
my head coach oh years later yeah we
were all like it was all intertwined wow
but i've always always loved benson
because bowling was out stayed out in
colorado yeah yeah he's out there you
know he was the you know he helped out
the university of northern uh colorado
program and he's the one who brought
geichi and mixed martial arts and with
trevor whitman stuff like that so yeah
those are my games man that's crazy
second yeah crazy vincent henderson's
second day he's like yo girls get the
ufc i'm like me too i mean
you know i think every eve in
hollywood's like what's the goal uh to
be brad pitt like me too and nobody you
know they're like serving starbucks now
yeah how crazy is that both that is nuts
ufc we both made to the uc that is crazy
never like but then i went to that gym
and then there's no heavyweights and
then i navigated towards another gym in
aurora neighborhood karched him because
there's a heavyweight trained car when
there but oh yeah that was my first
experience so shout out to that's great
benton henderson i love that dude legend
so this fight for you a lot of people
more pressure than ever on this one more
pressure than ever and it was also a a
weird time this was this was a weird
time in mixed martial arts where the
pandemic hits
bellator the ufc started about two
months before finally i think they had
their first fight in may uh this fight
was in august uh after the pandemic hit
so it was just a weird time where there
was everything was up in the air so my
whole
the rest of my career was kind of up in
the air because i couldn't get this last
fight and did you don't you feel more
pressure than ever don't know this yeah
mainly because yeah obviously i chose to
go into free agency you're banking on
yourself banking on myself betting on
myself
against a guy like benson henderson the
the fight before this um when we had
fought you know i i beat him it was a
split decision i had a bad fifth round
obviously i mean you're fighting benson
henderson it's just he's tough to look
good against him it's really hard all
right let's hit it man let's check this
out so this fight a lot of pressure but
you're still you're still mike chandler
out there man yeah you know so once
again yeah i wanted to get get in his
face right away we knew he was going to
throw those those hard left kicks um i
hit him with a lot of right kicks in in
the first fight banged up his arms a lot
hit him to the body a couple times so i
just wanted to kind of i wanted to put
the pressure on him right away
um but he's always kind of pawn and he's
and he's really good at managing
distance he's really good at managing
distance you know what makes ben very
special is a is fight iq and he's pretty
good at everything everything you're not
you're just not gonna break he's not
spectacular anywhere but he's really
good everywhere and those guys are but
what makes him i think elite is his
mentality and his leather skin his skin
does not show i mean that first fight i
hit him with the my whole entire arsenal
on his face and not didn't have a
scratch didn't have any swelling nothing
by the way that that right hook that he
just threw my left rib over here still
hurts a year and a half later wow
and i i've had it worked on um it wasn't
a broken rib or anything and maybe it
was i don't know you basically got a
tattoo from benson hannah
the one kind of
thing that was going on in this fight my
myself and henry hoof were doing a lot
of stuff we were switching stances we
throw a right hand step forward with the
right with the right foot and switch to
southpaw right here i've switched to
south paul that was the second time i've
done it now in the fight and then that's
how the the fight ends i eventually hit
him with a
throw throw the right hand or no i throw
a right kick step through into a south
paw and put myself into a southpaw
position and drop him originally with
the left and that was the kind of the
crinkle that you brought into
the crinkle into this fight just to mix
it up yeah and and me and henry have
been working out there it is again the
kind of the stance switch
i hit him with another one so i guess
there was three three or four times it
happens but that's that's how training
is though too here's the right kick
switch stance oh no so i did that
yeah and it's one of those
shin hurt right there big time not bad
um
but we were doing a lot of that and a
lot of times you train stuff and it
doesn't come out for a while straight
left
and then it was that punch right there
where it looks like even even the guys
in the booth were like it looked like he
didn't hit him but i hit him basically
right on top of the head and it that was
what kind of put him out and this was
this was like
i guess that is powerless i guess i mean
i'd rather get finished like you
finished benson than the way you
finished hooker which i find extremely
disrespectful but um
that one's terrible but you know he's
pretty shook up man that's how much
power you have dude yeah what i'm saying
and then how happy you're
yeah i've been there man when i thought
metron like
the ufc wanted me to sign a new
six-fight deal and i was like no let me
win this one and then negotiate and then
all my sponsors were all predicated off
me went in that fight to re
sign so it's like so much pressure man
and i felt so relieved did you just when
this fight over like oh thank god this
was uh this was the most relief i've
ever had since i went i lost i lost
three fights in a row and then i i won
my you know i finally got back on the
winning track um that was when i that
was the second most relief i've ever had
in my entire life because think about
that dude that hit him straight on the
jaw
yeah so this one was straight on the jaw
boom and it even it caught the shoulder
like a yeah a little bit of a and then
this one was on top of the head oh that
kind of just gives you yeah yeah he was
all right and that one on the top of the
head is what shut the door give him the
old c-spine
c-spine shake-up yeah that's tough
yeah daddy jumps in yeah you just have
to feel such a sense of relief right
there dude that's the big hug like dang
just hold me it was pulled me in we did
just hold me yeah i was like we did it
just think about it dude you know you
lost fights before that you lose this
one free agency is going to be pretty
tough you don't have a lot of
negotiating power or even a lackluster
performance i mean you know ufc is going
to use that against you hey benson we
cut them years ago and you barely you
barely beat him the first time the
second time you didn't look that great i
mean and that's nothing against the ufc
it's business it's in the negotiations
it's part of business
let's take a little break from breaking
down some of michael chandler's
amazing fights because man online
shopping isn't slowing down anytime soon
the pandemic slowing down but online
shopping is a booming and you need to
keep your business
ready to go it needs to keep up with the
pace and my friends at ship station got
you covered man you never have to worry
about shipping ever again make the
switch to a solution that handles all
your shipping needs quickly it's
affordable it's painless shipstation is
already trusted by over a hundred
thousand e-commerce sellers keep track
of orders from any sales channel easy
easily find the best shipping and
carrier with deeply discounted rates
deep man
save time by funneling all your orders
in one simple interface no matter what
you're selling manage every order amazon
ebay etsy your own website like a lot of
my friends do they they're doing their
merch they're doing whatever man it's
their own website and they're using
shipstation to get it to you on time
save money as well when you compare
carry options and choose the best
shipping solution every single time
save your sani knowing your orders are
handled and you're getting the best
rates possible all right no wonder 98 of
companies that use shipstation for a
year keep using it for as long as
they're in business and it's that good
ship station man ship more and less time
with ship station use my code shob sch
aub to get a 60 day free trial that's
two months free of no hassle stress free
shipping just go to shipstation.com
clicking the microphone at the top of
the page type in shob s-e-h-a-u-b ship
station make ship happen now let's get
back to michael chandler this is yeah
this is so this is your ufc debut here
against dan hooker who huge fan of the
the hangman hooker is a nightmare i
i i will we have a mutual friend in will
compton who's out in nashville played uh
for the raiders played for tennessee for
a long time will you know he's not
an expert in mma and always for your
fight to go how do you think you're
swinging around down and i told him i
said i gotta be honest man out of all
the matchups i'm not stoked they gave
him dan hooker trust me i felt the same
way i didn't tell him that i was not
gonna tell anybody that but they're not
doing many favors well the fight that's
exactly
they're not doing any favors like hooker
is a sack well because you got to you
got to lay the groundwork too the fight
before this dustin poirier and him
fought to a 25-minute war you know and
there was a couple times where he hurt
dustin correct you know and dustin
porter is the number one guy in the
world at that time or number two guy in
the world
um you know so
i knew it and he's he poses a lot of
problems he's freaking he
he's he's listed at six one he looked
like he felt like he was six four sure
you know i'm just standing there at the
weigh-ins looking up and i'm like whoa
what did i get myself and he's also a
guy his mentality like he has that
championship mentality he does you're
not breaking down you're breaking that
no you keep finding these [ __ ] dudes
that don't break at your level that's
what you get yes but dan hooker hey
you're not going to scare him can bully
him you're not going to scare him and
then also it's like he's just a tough
customer like again he's a he's long
he's gangly you know so and he's good i
didn't love this fight for you so as far
as pressure wise obviously benson
henderson insane entire
trajectory of your career is based off
of that fight a lot of pressure first
ufc fight end and it's a conor mcgregor
fight co-main event on a huge
pay-per-view big boy um to be honest i
didn't feel a lot of pressure in this
fight and that's and that's when i knew
that i had made the made the right
decision oh wow um you don't feel like
you had anything to prove to the fans
like that because
i think for i don't interrupt you i
think
you know you're the face of bellator for
a long time man so i think it it
justified a scott coker and bellator you
coming over getting a huge win you know
what i'm saying because they're rooting
for it they don't want you to leave and
then just get your ass kicked and you'll
see because it makes their brand look
bad so i think you have the pressure of
a saying hey yeah bellator guys are
pretty [ __ ] good man i bet you know i
was a world champ there for a reason and
then also you're representing so much
from that other organization going with
the
so i i don't know i felt like there'd be
a lot of pressure yeah i mean there
should when you when you lay out the
laundry list of reasons why there should
be pressure um it would make sense but
but i was good for some reason i just i
had made peace with i knew that i made
the right decision i knew i was right
where i was supposed to be right there
in abu dhabi on january 23rd
i was i knew i was right where i was
supposed to and also even your demeanor
like you came out like i don't think
i've ever seen you that way man you
looked just happy i was happy that that
was this was probably that this was the
happiest moment of my career walking
walking out to this fight because
i mean because
when you take it back to
i made a decision not a lot of people
would have the courage to make and i
don't say that to to pump my own ego i
just think i think i think so many
people in life we we play it safe and
we're too afraid to to take that leap
and stand on the edge of discomfort and
and really virtual uncertainty i have no
idea what was going to happen i could go
this could be my first loss in the ufc
and then the next fight i go 0-2 and
then i get cut and then the rest of my
career is what it is agree but you you
also know too from you know previous
kind of experience in the history with
ufc when you come from another
organization especially in a world champ
you're not getting those warm-up fights
man yeah like you're they're they they
wanna you know you're gonna sink or swim
yeah right away yeah right away yeah
luckily that's what i wanted yeah i
wanted i just again i mean your friend i
didn't like to dance i didn't either i
didn't tell anybody but i hate that's
why i hated the fight i told will i'm
like not crazy about it man he was you
bet i'm like i well but i'm i don't like
it man and will's like oh thanks for
nothing yeah exactly
but this uh yeah you just look like
you're in your element man yeah i was
man and it was just there was something
it was it was i was it was the only way
i can describe it is i was right where i
needed to be you know dan and then dan
is you can already see obviously the
height difference and i already fight
pretty
long
wide leg stance shorter but getting his
face i knew those leg kicks were going
to come i was able to check most of them
the plan was to close the distance i
assume and not let him you know use his
range
yes and that was the thing that was a
thing too everyone said dan hooker's
going to knee me you know knee my chin
into the first round
and actually i
jacked my i jacked up my jaw really bad
in this training camp a guy named bobby
casale hit me with a knee i'll show you
a video after this
straight up straight up
yeah talk about a talk about a voted
confidence where i'm like okay dan
hooker really is going to need me knock
me out i mean he is known for his foot
you know
so here you're just you're just because
you're he's rangy so it's so you're
trying to close the distance and a lot
of rival times level changes and faints
yeah it's how you want to how you want
to bring out a lot of the stuff and and
you're starting to see some of his
attacks he's not throwing a lot with his
hands he really only threw a lot of
kicks he's switching stances a little
bit it's feeling you out trying to keep
you at bay and then you just explode on
homeboy yeah i mean we went to the right
hand of the body and i did kind of there
was a little bit of frustration yeah a
little bit of like okay we're just going
to circle here but also i know i'm
winning the fight if i'm if i'm closing
the distance you know at least i'm
winning the
the battle between the ears that was the
first right hand of the body that we saw
so you're figuring out your distance
there and then it comes there it is a
lot of level changes and going to the
body yep because you can go upstairs i'm
assuming you're setting them up for that
big red yeah and and just i wanted to
work the body i if i can hit guys with
the right hand of the body it takes a
lot out of them here's another one that
was kind of a faint to a right overhand
yeah he's doing a lot of he's just
circling you know trying to he knows
your power is an issue yeah and each
time he each time he kind of switches
stances of course it changes up my
rhythm changes up makes me have to think
a little bit to the body again oh here
we go
and then i just kind of start to get you
know this is where the lay on the body
then there was the first one of the head
you're so aggressive man
that was when i that was when i though
the tide shifted right there big time
that kicked to the body there meaning
just as far as you know yeah i think
mentally he's like okay now this you
know little short stocky wrestler just
just front kick tipped me into the body
correct that was a leg kick that
actually landed and i'm like okay i'm
not gonna let that happen again i'm
gonna get in your face even more
let level change right hand of the body
left oh
god so
and then i almost went for the choke
there but luckily i getchan moves
veteran came out and just started going
to the back of the ear and then i'd have
no i've never never done never done a
backflip off the cage in my entire life
very very justin gateshead very justin
gateshead very justin very stupid of me
because i never practiced that in my
entire life decided to do it in front of
the biggest audience i've ever had in my
entire life yeah there's a guy named
johnny walker who was also like have you
ever seen the worm check this out
i'm a budding process prospect let me
let me show you the worm and then blows
the shoulders never been not
i available it i was like almost like
good job you did what you you know you
you took a chance and it worked out well
for you because there's nothing better
than that sad huge pain you take a
chance yeah and i also think for ufc
fans who they're familiar with you with
your work in bellator but like alright
let's see what this guy is all about and
then you get this just k this crazy kale
yeah over dan hooker you got the
american flag got the american flag
we're in front of like 2 000 people in
abu dhabi and i'm jumping up on the cage
like like i have a bunch of fans there
but i really don't because it's abu
dhabi you know from america
yeah so that's that right hand to the
body kind of shift overhand left kind of
like a left
left hook but but i did switch stances
right there
but it was all set up with the body
shots man you kept going back to the
well there and then yeah yeah
and then with the level changes and
stuff too i saw him start to i saw i saw
his hands started to come down he saw
his hands start to come down to defend
the takedown because yeah i mean the
only way that most people would say that
i beat dan hooker i'm not going to beat
him in a striking match i was i needed
to take him down but look at dc yeah dc
huge this was yeah this was yeah great
first time ever pretty legit though dude
you've never done a backflip like that
not off the cage no i've done a lot on
the on the ground from the ground to the
ground so i don't know why i did it but
i did and i'm assuming that that
combination is the henry hoof specialty
it's something that we we've worked on
he's a genius huh he's a genius and it's
and it's very simple even though that
that looked cool you know most of the
time when things look cool you think
well it must be very intricate all of
his stuff is just so simple and it works
really well for me i've fought and
trained in some systems that were just a
little bit too
a little bit too
intricate you know like for me
now that when the bullets are flying
yeah it's tough simple stuff i mean most
of the time i mean when you see when you
see 90 something percent of the
knockouts it's it's a it's usually the
meat and potatoes it's the meat i mean
you need to get a few back kicks and all
that [ __ ] but it's usually yeah i mean
the the jab the right hand the the body
the hooks the meat and potatoes exactly
and i'm not i'm the kind of guy where i
need to keep it as simple as possible in
order to be as as effective as i
possibly can be i also think with your
athletic ability and your power like you
don't need to do all that crazy i guess
yeah i mean that's that's true too i
think and that's that's part of why i
love putting pressure on guys because
when not only do they feel my presence
and they feel my pressure then all of a
sudden they feel the power correct so
now it's second guessing themselves
three different times three different
ways and then you start to take them out
of their game plan where they start to
think okay
i had an idea of who this guy was when i
was gonna fight him but i didn't quite
realize how fast and powerful and how
much pressure he was going to put on me
right away so it starts to make them
change their mentality right from the
get-go i think what else you have going
for before we get to the charles
oliveira fight
mainly all your your fights especially
in the ufc have been you know it's all
about your stand up yeah power your
powerful right hand stuff like that you
can [ __ ] wrestle man grapple haven't
shown him just chose not to yeah
like in the gate you find like if he
doesn't shoot a double i'm going to
freak out
i will tell you this right now i never
of course yes i did start chasing the
knockout and started chasing the big
shots and started maybe got a little bit
got a little bit ahead of myself being
at madison square garden fighting justin
gates you wanting to get get into a
brawl but there wasn't as many times as
as you would think there was openings to
get the takedown the way justin the way
justin gaichi closes his eyes puts his
head down and swings overhand brings his
hips really far back and there's a
barrier in between you and you and him
his head is between you his hands his
arms and his hips are way back behind
him so he's he's never in a great
position to get taken down and i think
that's why he doesn't get taken down a
lot i agree with that and then i also
you know the thing about justin geich
again i've been i knew justin was in
college just wrestling came over to
grudge training system and just
was this banshee man everyone's like gee
who is this kid yeah he just had
wrestling but his hips are insane dude
insane yeah he's he's fast he's special
special special he doesn't he doesn't
have a lot of crazy
fluid athletic movements but his ability
to move his hips back like very strong
hips and very i mean that's and that's
just years and years of being on
wrestling that too the the hip awareness
the body awareness yep
one thing is man when you're watching
this show flashback fight nights fight
companion fighting the kid king this
thing in the wing food truck whatever it
is your boys on kratom kratom is my
limitless pill listen i fired up
all freaking day stand up podcast
whatever it is your boys on kratom the
secret's out man that's my secret weapon
it's kratom and i need all the help i
can get you listeners know this and
viewers it's the best focused product
i've ever used best part it's all
natural
visit happy hippo herbals.com use promo
code
thick boy for 20 percent off for life
use that code as many times as you want
visit
happyhippoherbles.com use promo code
thick boy for 20 off for life
so you know you get the dan hooker the
huge knockout everybody knows your name
you're getting notoriety you're
following flying through the roof and
then you get the title shot here against
charles oliveira which i thought
going into the fight
the way the ufc works especially at the
the
the upper echelon it's about styles the
fifth guy could be the number one guy
but the fifth guy can't be the number
four guy that's all about style matchups
i thought this was actually an easier
fight for you than a geichi or a dustin
poirier i thought charles oliver was an
easier fight and you proved me i said
that on my show and you proved me
correct in the first round where again
if this goes on
20 seconds longer your world champ yeah
or if there was a different a different
referee not to say that
the
the ref did anything wrong but but as we
see there there could be a different
referee inside these different stoppages
and and one guy because it's that's the
hardest job in the entire world being a
referee is the hardest job in the
institute i beg to differ it's
challenging
yeah insurgents be tough well i mean
that's yeah i mean there's there's
things like firefighter navy seals no i
guess i don't when people saw the
toughest job in the world like
but as far as dec split second decision
making and then once you make that
decision you have a multitude of
millions and millions of people just
criticizing your decision you know it's
one of those up there i would say maybe
maybe that's just because that's the
world i live in no i mean fighter state
all times toughest job in the world i
beg to differ for sure just get better
at your job but then also
i'm sorry but then also
you know you look at the judging yeah
it's like i wouldn't want that job like
i would yeah it's like what the
and there's no repercussions like nobody
gets held to a standard refs do a little
bit because they're they're such a
familiar face you know so we get true
the refs become celebrities and then
online they get annihilated sometimes so
they deal with a little bit for the most
part they get it right like they're yeah
i agree it is a tough job but the
toughest let's be this be cool but i do
think you know for the most part they do
have to be held responsible and they are
yeah and usually they make good
decisions sometimes you know so many
fights and make bad decisions
but the judging yeah to me is a much
bigger issue judging was really bad even
you know i hate how we all accept it how
everyone goes that's part of mma it's
like dude because you know in the nfl in
the raiders cincinnati game they made a
horrible mistake you know what the nfl
did they pulled all those referees and
went you guys aren't referring during
the playoffs it's too big of a deal well
that's they got suspended well and
that's yeah i mean that's the way that's
the way it should be too i mean yeah the
fact that there's no repercussions or
even
it would be nice if there was a public
hearing where we could where we could
see as we sit here today when you look
at last fights last weekend sean
strickland versus her manson yes and sal
damato
judged the fight for jack hermansson he
should be suspended for six months or he
should at least be sat there
in front of a public forum live on
youtube for him to explain himself and
for the media or fighters or coaches or
whoever to ask him questions to see what
is going through his head because only
through information of of understanding
how how he saw that fight for jack or
manson can we glean
the information to make our decisions on
how we should still fight i don't know
how you can argue that no you know what
i'm saying like i'd love to hear his
argument but again they're not held
accountable no and like he that should
be a six months it is and i'm afraid to
even sit here and talk about him or say
his name because he could be my my judge
and you you don't want to think it's
subjective you don't want to think that
there could be any kind of bias but it
is it is kind of crazy or even some of
these
boxing refs who come over oh they and
you're just having to start boxing yeah
i'm just like straight corrupt well but
i'm saying yo that but also like they
they only knew boxing and then all of a
sudden they come over and they start
judging me it's insane but it's just so
insane as uh a ufc fan we should go
that's part of mma it's like what that's
222 men it is and like these guys
paychecks like exactly and then also
like
although the ufc is more forgiving but
it's like if you lose a fight man you go
back you gotta go back in the queue and
soak like to in just to get a title shot
is damned and impossible you'll see at
155 pounds yeah you know how much of a
badass you have to be to get a [ __ ]
title shot yeah and then you got this
raff who might [ __ ] it up for you yeah
come on sal i think it's ct all right uh
let's hit this charles oliveira fight
love this for you i thought you were a
nightmare of a matchup for him i still
believe that i think you guys fight
again
um
you know going to this fight you get a
title shot obviously you've been a world
champion before so it's not unfamiliar
territory he does you know i know it's
the nerve he does have a you know the
quit gene in him which i liked
especially for you going this fight and
dude you you kind of you came out like a
banshee
obviously no fear you you're pressure
you're aggressive you're fighting like
michael chandler which some guys change
when they get to the big show but for
you it was just yeah that was out gate
it was and that was that was the same so
you saw the right hand of the body left
hand right there again there it is so
we're kind of hitting with kind of the
same stuff he shot he shot he shoots and
i filthy guillotine yeah and it was uh
it was kind of one of those deals where
i was like yeah i'm probably not gonna
get this so i'm gonna go you know right
don't waste your energy and uh kind of
fight out of it i give him my back which
this is when joe is like this is a
horrible position for for chandler and
and of course that's a wrestler in you
yeah and i love to give my back i love
to give my back to people because i
think i always get out i always get the
one-on-one i i will hold on to this
one-on-one now um you're not worried
about getting submitted here but i'm not
in this crazy decorated submission
that's what i was gonna use sometime
about a guy who has the most submission
bonuses ever and maybe it's that was
ignorance on my part maybe you know also
probably the reason why you're there you
know what i'm saying like that belief in
yourself gets you there it's our whole
day i see a game to play but you are you
you're doing the baseball bat when i
tell my son when someone gets his back
baseball bat this was ill-advised yet
entertaining okay so
right there and that's what a lot of
people would say too and but i knew
down there where he has a figure four it
starts to loosen up and once if if i
hold that arm right there there's not
much that he can do plus he's starting
to realize that he's going to be he's
getting in more in a
in a more stuck position or a more
leading to now yeah do you remember when
you cut him that's that's great i hit
him with a left hook yep
i'd like to say it was my head that
headbutted him on the on that john
it was you don't think so he was already
bleeding before that okay it'd be cool
if he was though
even though that's it's legal but if
you're a michael chandler fan here and
you're you're tuning in you're like well
this is worst case scenario you have the
best missionaries of all time the ufc
most decorated submission artist he you
know he has a body lock and he has his
back that's one of the hardest positions
to ever get out of that when a guy with
long arm long legs has a figure four but
i get the two on i get the two on one
and i'm able to athletically just spin
out and i do it in practice all the time
um so confident there i am confident
there it's you know probably not the
best idea you know because you could
lose a fight or you could sit there a
whole round because of it um
but from here now i just kind of smelled
blood you know i thought you're going
hard in the paint right now yeah i
thought i thought he's really starting
to second-guess himself so i'm just i'm
just going for broke it's it's in me i'm
like
i think i come down into his guard here
in a second
and i'm surprised you just don't let him
up there you go he gets up and then now
it's on which i was i was happy about
yeah because so i was chasing the right
hand to the body and that's where that
will eventually be my double eyes that
left right hand with the left right see
here
here yeah you're talking minute 52 left
too
yeah i mean
you know what some refs would stop that
yeah and is that frustrating for you to
watch no not really because i mean he's
defending there though yeah he is i i i
would probably move on his part no i
wouldn't have yeah smart veteran move
and also championship fight i use a 10
on the side of let them go a little
longer so it's clear yeah and i don't
want to get annihilated on twitter if
i'm a ref you know something let's let
let him go a little bit and then just
from here i thought he he obviously he's
a long body and he's a he's a jiu jitsu
he's a jiu jitsu guard player so he's
very good at defending just putting
stuff in in between yourself and him
with his legs with his arms did you
train a lot of that in camp i did a lot
of big time jiu jitsu like black belt
cards and stuff like that yeah and just
moving guys
i gotta be honest i was surprised that
this fight
was this much on the ground yeah
yeah i mean he uh
i think he he realized pretty soon right
away that that the pressure that i was
gonna bring he didn't really want to and
he shot yeah first one shoot which
surprised me and also here i think he
probably thought he was gonna maybe
catch me on something and landed a
couple of really great elbows
you know yeah you're being ashamed right
now but it's also you know i think too
for a lot of guys is when they go oh
charles oliveira he's a black belt yeah
he's a black man i'm like
oh you think chandler you know it's not
his first rodeo man yeah
it's uh that black belt turns into a
white belt pretty pretty quick
especially after all the but also black
belt too i don't even have a belt
beltless i mean
if i get a ward belt i'll give you a
black belt thanks i am a black belt i
don't know how it works exactly but you
know yeah
so here you know now it's now now i i'm
in you know you're comfortable now i'm
in recovery mode though too i'm in like
there's a few seconds left let's just uh
let's end this round
walk away from him hopefully he's second
guessing himself
i mean the only reason you would the
crowd's limit the only reason why you
give that 10-8 rounds because he had the
the body lock right he had your back
definitely a 10-9 for let's say 10-9
10-9 fair there yeah definitely won that
round wobbled them
probably better they didn't stop it
early i mean i wish they did being your
friend but you know of course yeah it's
like that'd be that'd be great
that leg kick got me but it's all right
is that the same leg kick that hurts
the low leg okay with homeboy yeah the
low leg kicks are always the worst yeah
that was the good shot by good timing
shot god dude and that guilting's pretty
pretty deep
boom
yeah his eye was bleeding before that
was that left hook
yeah i was doing a lot of right hands of
the body left boom right behind the head
there boom then that
the funny thing is in the dan when i
knocked down dan hooker i went i went
for the choke and then decided
to go against the punches but with this
one i actually wish i would have went
for the guillotine he's got a longer
skinnier neck to at least
kind of go no arm in the kind of a naked
guillotine i wish i would have kind of
in hindsight i wouldn't wish i would
have but it's it's hindsight that's 20
20. yeah great and then i thought you
know after a round like that like
charles
right there
came out went right hand right hand to
the body with no with didn't have my
hand up really bad
bad decision bad technique and then he
uh that was the beginning of the end
right there that was a legitimate
stoppage
charles oliveira your lightweight
champion yeah man he's a beast this
moment you do you realize what's going
on you realize you lost the championship
or you're literally yeah yeah i know i
remember i remember being there i
remember dan being in front of me and i
remember seeing his yellow shorts
because they stick out like a sore thumb
i remember seeing his yellow shorts run
across and him jump over the cage
nothing was like that goddammit it's
like well there it went yep that was the
opportunity of uh you know in a lifetime
yeah and kudos to him too because after
that first round i thought this this is
going exactly i predicted he's gonna
come out he's gonna realize chandler's
different animal there's that quit gene
in them yeah i was off man he came out
and it fired him up i think losing that
round i think that championship
mentality came out in him and he came
out ready to go for sure and and it
continued to show that charles
oliveira's got some sharp hands you know
his his gooey tie his kickboxing is is a
lot sharper than a lot of people have
given him credit for
um
you know i think but the biggest thing
is just the overarching feeling that
since making the decision to go to the
ufc
knocking out benson henderson coming in
knocking out dan hooker and then
getting the title shot like i thought
that was my moment i thought that was i
was like you couldn't have scripted this
thing any better this is a perfect
storybook ending cinderella story this
was absolutely perfect so i think
whenever all those all that i was 100
confident that i was going to be the
champion that night
because it all worked out so perfectly
you couldn't have scripted any better
and then all of a sudden it doesn't so
it was almost just i was it was
confusion mixed with obviously you know
tears and the sadness yeah so it's just
uh
it's a crazy crazy sport but that's why
we love it i mean i can sit here and
watch this and somehow still be happy
that charles oliveira this kid from the
favelas of brazil great story who had a
really up and down kind of spotty career
couldn't really be relied upon and i
don't think six years ago you would say
yeah i guess wouldn't be you know
dominant world guy couldn't even make
guy couldn't even make weight
yeah issues you know i cornered miles
jury whenever he fought charles oliveira
charles didn't make weight and i just
remember that was the day that i was
like i don't like this guy yep so it was
kind of years later it was almost
somewhat of a revenge too i was like
this guy doesn't deserve to be fighting
for the title if you couldn't even make
weight that many you missed weight that
many times you know i've weighed in 100
something times i've never missed weight
um but
he's cleaned things up he's come back as
a consummate professional he's our
inspirational story and now he's looking
great so in a weird way you know you
have you have a certain amount of
respect for every single person that you
step into the octagon with caged with
the mixed martial arts landscape with of
course
but even for him seeing the way he's
come back it's a great story for the
young kids in brazil can i can i get
your prediction we'll end on this well i
have one more question but we'll end on
this um prediction for
charles oliveira justin gaichy
championship fight
man my uh
my heart says gaiji i want gay i think i
want gaichi i think gateshead i'd like
to see gaichi win that title but man i'm
telling you i think
i think charles oliveira has more tools
i think charles has now proven himself
that he's tougher than we thought
i think do i don't think he's gonna be
able to take justin down as easily as he
thinks he's going to case in point for
me yes um
but
i think charles i think charles gets the
nod in that one i do interesting i mean
i see it going either way i think for
justin
again i i still think to me and i know
it's crazy the jury's still out for me
on on charles oliveira even after seeing
that i do like how he responded
you know obviously you know this you've
been in there you shared a knockdown for
five rounds with my justin gates he's
just such a different animal so um it is
it's a great fight it is and and
gateshe's got a great chance i mean and
that's the thing too you look at i mean
obviously charles charles finished me
right there but then i fought gaichi and
took everything geichi had nuts and he
wasn't able to finish me and i obviously
got dropped that one time but it it just
goes to show the perfectly timed
perfectly placed shots anybody can get
knocked out and that's exactly what
charles did put it right on the chin
when i wasn't ready for it it's a shot
so you don't see coming that really
knock you out agree i'll make a
prediction now we'll end on this i think
we'll do this again the next three
fights we watch will your next three ufc
fights i think goes tony ferguson conor
mcgregor and then you fight for the
title i like that and i think we'll be
here watching it you'll be world champ
at the end of 2010 this year uh i'll say
by early 2023 okay i like that that's my
prediction it'll be a perfect uh that
would be a perfect little run yup down
with that this was fun it was fun thank
you
of work minute chandler scare us i get
up i go hard like i'm george harris make
plays break lanes push break chains
[Music]